dans un épisode précédent à quelques
jeux faisant peser des menaces sur les
sociétés humaines tight surcharge de
travail maladie dépendance aux
ressources l'agriculture était un fléau
et jamais je te laisse faire mais en
trois épisodes mais pourtant
l'agriculture est une voie qui a été
emprunté pour la plupart des sociétés
humaines et du coup la question se pose
depuis
[Musique]
bienvenue au vortex moi c'est clotilde
pour le premier épisode d'une série sur
quelques grandes révolutions de
l'histoire humaine
alors non on va parler ni de la prise de
la bastille ni de la bombe atomique mais
deux choses bien plus fondamental vous
ne vous êtes jamais demandé pourquoi de
vinci a pu peindre la joconde la
préhistoire et pourquoi kennedy a été
assassiné
la préhistoire et pourquoi la
préhistoire allez on remet tout dans
l'ordre comme l'agriculture est à peu
près la plus grosse claque qu'on se soit
pris dans la tronche de toute notre
histoire
il fallait bien deux épisodes pour tout
expliquer bon d'abord il faut dire une
chose quitte à briser le mythe mais
l'agriculture n'est pas une invention
aucun chasseur cueilleur ne s'est jamais
réveillé le matin se disant tiens si je
me mettais à planter le manioc devant la
maison plutôt que nous casser le cul en
trouver dans la forêt ensuite personne
n'a jamais fait la découverte du
principe de l'agriculture tous les
peuples de la terre dans l'ordre même
ceux qui n'occupent tous les peuples de
la terre même ceux qui ne cultive pas
connaissent le principe de la
reproduction végétale lafleur donne le
fruit qui donne le noyau qui donne la
plante etc etc
c'est pas des gens dépendants des
ressources végétales pour leur
nourriture que vous allez apprendre ça
la plupart des cueilleurs encourage
d'ailleurs la prolifération des plantes
qui leur sont utiles quand ils les
croisent en répondant leurs graines en
éliminant leurs parasites ou en coupant
leurs parties malades ces procédés
existent partout et il est donc
impossible de parler d'une invention
comme pour la machine à vapeur ou le
mélodica ces quelques gestes sont en
réalité la base des soins qu'un
agriculteur prodigue à ces cultures et
de niort c'est lors de la cueillette
[Musique]
mon
la question c'est de savoir si
l'agriculture c'est seulement une
invention humaine ou ya une fourmilière
sur le pied de ronan c'est pas grave ou
s'il ya d'autres espèces qui cultive ça
tombe bien que tu parles de fourmies
parce que justement ouais il fourmis
cultive elle cultive des champignons
mais ces fourmis coups de feu y coupe
des feuilles des arbres puis on voit les
colonnes de fourmi qui ramène les
failles dans la fourmilière en fait
elles donnent les feuilles à manger à un
champignon et le champion grandi et en
échange le champignon donne des sortes
de petits bulbes à manger aux enfants
elle s'en occupe le taillage enlève les
parties affectées et c est le désinfecte
parce qu'elles ont des bactéries qui
produisent des antibiotiques et en plus
il ya de la sélection tu matin un
incident non simulation mais je suis
quoi faire mais en plus il ya plein
d'autres espèces tu as les poissons qui
cultive des algues tu as plein de
l'espèce du scarabée qui cultive des
champignons et s'il ya des exemples en
latin avec du végétal mais avec de
l'élevage et à des fourmis qu'ils
élèvent des pucerons en fait les
récupère le miellat qui est excrété par
une l'anus du puits seront récupérés le
milieu là avec leurs petites mandibules
à la niche du puits seront et elles vont
se nourrir avec d'accord on
ça fait cette confiture franchement avec
ça non je pense qu'on va supermarché on
achète des blés mûrs des framboises ou
quelque chose d'autre
c'est dégueulasse vous avez compris mon
argument le principe est connu partout
et depuis toujours même au delà des
frontières du genre humain n'en reste
pas moins que ce type de vie n'est pas
celui des premiers humains qui étaient
des prédateurs en adoptant l'agriculture
les humains ont franchi dans l'art
histoire un cap se sont mis à jouer le
rôle de la nature c'est à dire celui de
veiller à sa place à ce que les animaux
et les plantes se reproduise la raison
pour laquelle ils ont fait ça c'est
parce que la nature ne fournissait pas
de rendement assez constant en gros elle
faisait mal le job
ils ont donc commencé à la remplacer
mettant ainsi le doigt dans un engrenage
infernal pour continuer à bénéficier de
que la nature leur donner avec abondance
auparavant ils devaient désormais
produire un travail considérable pour
simplement maintenir les rendements de
cueillette sauvage
résultat des courses nos chasseurs
cueilleurs avait du pain en quantité
mais il s'était fait piéger
il était devenu agriculteur avec tous
les inconvénients dont on a parlé la
dernière fois on voit qu'en réalité on
ne devient pas agriculteur par plaisir
ou même par choix ou devient agriculteur
sans s'en rendre compte et parce qu'on a
quasiment pas d'autres alternatives
qu'on appelle à tort invention de
l'agriculture c'est en fait un processus
long et qui a lieu sur plusieurs
générations
mais pour que ce processus puisse
s'enclencher il faut des conditions
naturelles très particulière il faut
d'abord un climat adapté c'est à dire un
interglaciaire on l oublie souvent mais
l'apparition du genre humain est
concomitant d'une succession d'airs
glaciaire les périodes tempéré dit
interglaciaire sorte de parenthèse
chaudes ont été très minoritaire c'est
pas hasard donc si l'agriculture est
apparu pendant une période chaude
l'holocène qui a débuté il ya douze
mille ans la chaleur et des espèces
sauvages à domestiquer c'est un bon
début mais il faut aussi et surtout des
conditions sociales avec des animaux
comme les humains on peut jamais se
satisfaire d'une explication biologique
ou environnementale
désolé les eaux tout passe toujours par
le prisme de la culture et de
l'organisation sociale la preuve rapide
que l'agriculture n'est pas qu'un fruit
des conditions naturelles c'est que le
scène n'est pas le premier
interglaciaire que connaît l'espèce
humaine durant l'interclassé heures
précédant le risque burnes qui est
survenu environ 130 mille ans personne
n'a inventé l'agriculture pourtant les
sapiens ou même les néandertaliens
connaissez bien cette époque le principe
de la reproduction des végétaux si
l'agriculture est apparue il ya dix
mille ans et pas 130 milles c'est qu'il
y avait des conditions sociales qui
n'étaient pas réunies la première fois
reste à savoir lesquels comme souvent en
sciences humaines c'est complètement
illusoire de chercher une cause unique
les facteurs sociaux qui ont permis à
plusieurs sociétés d'inventer
l'agriculture à peu près au même moment
à l'échelle de l'histoire humaine sont
forcément multiples parmi les
différentes hypothèses qui ont été
avancées pour expliquer par les
structures sociales l'apparition de
l'agriculture
il ya notamment celle du chercheur
français jacobin qui avait proposé que
se soit déroulée une sorte de révolution
symbolique
en somme un bouleversement des
mentalités visible dans l'art des
sociétés préhistoriques
là encore une fois cette hypothèse n'est
pas suffisante des découvertes matériel
que nous avons fait porter la
chronologie est ce que c'était avant
après pendant tout du long
bah c'est pas facile à dire pour
l'américain marshall salissent ce serait
plutôt la parution du pouvoir qui
motiverait la création d'un stock et
donc d'une production agricole mais
encore une fois difficile de démêler la
cause de la conséquence la plupart du
temps en préhistoire c'est du côté de
l'ethnologie qui arrive de nouvelles
idées stimulante
l'anthropologue français philippe
descola à lui pris le problème à
l'envers en étudiant des sociétés qui
ont justement décidé de ne pas basculer
dans l'élevage dans son article pour que
les indiens d'amazonie non pas
domestiqué le pécari d'escaut la
considère que l'élevage du pécari alors
c'est un genre de petits sangliers
auraient modifié trop en profondeur le
rapport des indiens animiste aux animaux
pour les animistes les animaux et
certaines plantes sont spirituellement
similaires aux humains toutes les
espèces peuvent prendre l'apparence
d'autres et elles entretiennent des
relations sociales très complexe or moi
je vois pas pk british pour elle mais
ton aloe vera aussi pour être impeccable
cool tu te rends compte exercer sa
domination sur une espèce que l'on
conçoit comme son égal fort et ainsi
compromettre l'équilibré de la nature
pour cette raison les indiens d'amazonie
non pas domestiqué de pécari mais nous
en revanche eu aucun mal à domestiquer
le chien un animal arrivé assez
récemment avec les européens et qui ne
peut plaît pas leur mythologie et donc
avec lequel il n'avait pas de relation à
préserver la condition principale de
l'émergence de l'agriculture celle qui
fait qu'une société accepte de mettre le
doigt dans l'engrenage serait si on suit
cet exemple une mutation dans les
rapports entre les humains et leur
environnement
les plantes et les animaux ne serait
plus investi d'une dimension spirituelle
mais deviendrait comme des objets qu'il
est possible de manipuler
dit comme ça c'est assez révélateur du
rapport de nos sociétés industrielles à
leur environnement
l'idée que tout est disponible pour
l'exploitation humaine naît et se
développe en même temps que la
révolution néolithique la révolution
industrielle n'est rien d'autre qu'une
accélération technique d'état d'esprit
reste fondamentalement le même
cette mentalité développer à l'échelle
du capitalisme mondialisé avec sept ou
huit milliards de consommateurs
mais on sait tous maintenant absolument
plus viable les prises de conscience
récente tend ainsi d'enrayer dix mille
ans d'histoire humaine
pas facile de faire émerger les prémices
d'une nouvelle révolution c'est la fin
de la vidéo merci à tous de l'avoir
regardé vous pouvez laisser des
commentaires mais aussi nous retrouver
sur le discorde pour discuter de cet
épisode de la série
et puis bah lâcher un pouce bleus et
puis à la prochaine salut
[Musique]